la vérité est à jamais rêvé tafara les
routes de toi sinon je vais arriver de
tir ardisson a sûrement pas je l'avais
en vrai ça va oui non t'as jamais tout à
fait un rêve doc gynéco lui pas
quelqu'un pendant l'émission tu razer
justement bail et christine je veux des
jeux des réponses
allez-y moins de nom mais on voit mal de
quelqu'un de connu non l'ont battu et
ouvrait alors le dernier mais vain peu
de choquer je le connais pas c'était
c'est un plan iii et iv toi et diego ton
gardes du corps il est sexy mort sulens
beau il est vrai il est sexy la petite
barbe et tout et tout est en fait il
était devant la porte faudra ensemble je
te dit tout et donne à coup tu dis
faisons entrer diego 1 et l'antre du
coup voilà il est doit ramener cet
athlète c'est qu'il est très très sexy
quand même je vois soumaré alors mathieu
qui se disent on nettoie plus sur des
goûts changent très vite deux fils
s'opérer
[Applaudissements]
les mariés rien à voir on embrasse sa
femme d'ailleurs que j'adore voilà donc
vous vous à une fois j'ai fait un rêve
de geek et les rôtis nom mathieu dit la
vérité au moins monsieur brigue
avez-vous dans un rêve je raconte un
truc et vous m'avez dit texto d'un bref
s'était couché ta mère ta gueule doublé
révisable elle est connue bah oui alors
j'ai rêvé d'elle en tunisie quoi pas
longtemps en tunisie ah ouais c'est
arrivé un petit truc enfin j'avais ces
affaires j'ai posé ses affaires à côté
de mon lit tu te souviens j'avais ces
affaires un est en fait le fait d'avoir
ces affaires un peu intime à côté de moi
ça m'a inspiré dans la nuit je vais
vomir
[Applaudissements]
on vous a mis des petits sacs on suit
son bonhomme bien sûr si vous avez un
problème il ya des masques à oxygène qui
vont tomber